Jimmy Kimmel hosted the 90th annual
Academy Awards on Sunday night and
slayed his opening monologue China all
you need to know the late night host
made fun of last year's Best Picture
flub this year when you hear your name
called
don't get up right away and addressed
the hashtag me too movement head-on
Oscar is the most beloved and respected
man in Hollywood keeps his hands where
you can see them never says a rude word
and most importantly no penis at all the
comedian called for real change in
Hollywood we can work together to stop
sexual harassment in the workplace if we
can do that women will only have to deal
with harassment all the time at every
other place they go and priests the
success of Black Panther and Wonder
Woman I remember a time when the major
studios didn't believe a woman or a
minority could open a superhero movie
and the reason I remember that time is
because it was March of last year Kimmel
teased 22 year old nominee timothy
sha'lame timothy is missing paw patrol
to be here tonight and 88 year old
Christopher Plummer
how does lin-manuel Miranda compared to
the real Alexander Hamilton but the best
moment of all Kimmel closed his opening
monologue with a little help from Helen
Mirren promising the Oscar winner with
the shortest speech a jet ski retail
price 17 $9.99 Helen Mirren not included